>> Bill: JACKSONVILLE,
FLORIDA, OPENED UP ITS BEACHES
YESTERDAY, THE MAYOR WAS WITH US
TO EXPLAIN HIS DECISION A WEEK
AGO.
HE IS BACK TODAY AND THANK YOU
FOR COMING BACK IN GOOD
AFTERNOON TO YOU.
YOU KNOW WHAT EVERYBODY WAS
SAYING AND WHAT THEY SAID OVER
THE WEEKEND, HAVE YOU HAD ANY
PROBLEMS?
WE MET WE HAVEN’T.
IN FACT, AFTER THE INITIAL
OPENING, THE CROWDS REALLY
THINNED OUT.
PEOPLE ARE FOLLOWING THE
RESTRICTIONS FROM SIX TO 11 IN
THE MORNING, NO SUNBATHING, NO
CHAIRS, NO COOLERS, KEEP WALKING
AND KEEP YOUR DISTANCE.
IN FACT, I’M ON THE TASK FORCE
TO REOPEN THE STATE AND THAT
TASK FORCE IS DISCUSSING
POTENTIALLY USING THEIR WAY
JACKSONVILLE’S RESTRICTIONS FOR
ITS BEACHES WERE A MODEL AROUND
THE STATE.
>> Bill: THAT’S INTERESTING.
BACK TO LAST WEEK, YOU ARE BEING
CRITICIZED BECAUSE IT LOOKED
LIKE IN SOME OF THE IMAGES THAT
PEOPLE WERE NOT 6 FEET APART.
WHAT DID YOU SAY TO THEM?
>> THAT WE HAD -- OUR BEACHES
EACH HAVE A MAYOR.
THERE ARE THREE MAYORS AT THE
BEACHES AND THEY WERE OUT THERE,
POLICE WERE OUT THERE, FIRE AND
RESCUE ARE OUT THERE.
ALL THE FEEDBACK THAT I GOT WAS
PEOPLE WERE PRACTICING SOCIAL
DISTANCING, THEY WEREN’T GETTING
INTO LARGE GROUPS.
SO WE JUST HAD TO WEATHER THE
CRITICISM, AND I EXPECT THAT
WILL CONTINUE AS CITIES AND
COUNTIES AND STATES REOPEN IN
THEIR OWN WAY BASED ON THE DATA
THEY HAVE AND THE JUDGMENT THEY
MAKE.
THERE WILL BE CRITICS AND IF
YOU’RE NOT WILLING TO ACCEPT
THAT, YOU’RE NOT GOING TO MAKE
PROGRESS.
ONE>> Bill: AND A LOOSENING THE
POLICIES?
>> IT IS AT 4.8% NOW, WE ARE
FOLLOWING THE WHITE HOUSE AND
PRESIDENT TRUMP’S PHASES TO
REOPEN TO TAILOR TO OUR COUNTY.
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT JUST GOT US
$160 MILLION IN CARE’S FUNDS,
PUTTING $40 MILLION OF THAT TO
PROVIDE RENT, UTILITY, AND
MORTGAGE RELIEF.
35 MILLION TO EXPAND TESTING, SO
WE ARE ON THE ROAD TO RECOVERY.